avec monsieur groserin nous demandons la
suppression de cet article qui je dois
dire est pour le moins étonnant
l'Assemblée nationale a voté
l'exonération c'est un cadeau fiscal
démesuré
incompréhensible scandaleux et pour tout
dire obsène pour attirer les fédérations
sportives il faudrait non seulement les
exonérer de tout impôt mais même
appliquer cela aux salariés de ces de
ces fédérations donc la FIFA qui comme
chacun sait est un organisme
particulièrement pauvre et qui n'a pas
les moyens de payer l'impôt ni que ses
salariés mal payés et sous-payés payent
également l'impôt obtient du
gouvernement français un cadeau fiscal
démesuré alors je me suis interrogé pour
quelle raison ce cadeau fiscal et on
nous explique que il s'agit de la
géopolitique du sport et que en attirant
les fédérations internationales mais en
réalité en premier lieu la FIFA la
France y gagnerait quelque chose elle y
gagnerait quoi l'organisation des est
spor se font dans les fédérations je ne
suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que j'espère que
les Jeux Olympiques seront un succès
mais nous en verront le coup cet
amendement n'a aucun sens j'ajoute de
surcroix qu'il m'apparaît accessoirement
anticonstitutionnel parce qu'il faudra
expliquer pourquoi les salariés d'une
fédération sportive peuvent ne pas payer
d'impôt contrairement aux autres
citoyens voilà pourquoi nous demandons
la suppression de cet article je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur
oui mais chers collègues effectivement
c'est un amendement qui enfin je vois
qu'il y a plusieurs amendements et je ne
il me semblait que la commission des
finances ne pouvait pas ne pas déposer
un amendement de
suppression de cette disposition qui est
de mon point de vue incompréhensible et
qui est perçu comme une forme de
provocation d'abord parce que je ne P je
ne crois pas savoir que le monde du
sport et même au niveau des fédérations
internationales est fait la moindre
demande on devine bien vous parlez
d'attractivité monsieur le ministre mais
si
l'attractivité c'est de venir proposer
d'accueillir des fédérations sportives
je dis bien sportives
internationales dont la santé
financière est plutôt favorable et leur
faire des cadeaux fiscaux que jamais
j'espère personne n'accepterait à cette
hauteur il suffit de regarder les
cadeaux fiscaux il y aurait des
exonérations d'impôts sur les sociétés
de TVA de CFE de CVAE et puis comme ça
ne suffit pas on propose au
personnel une exonération d'impôt sur
leur venue pendant 5 ans c'est
scandaleux vous l'avez dit c'est inique
je pense qu'il faut siffler vite la fin
de la partie parce que c'est également
vu comme une forme de provocation par le
monde sportif et notamment le monde
sportif amateur comme je ne veux pas
jouer contre mon camp le sport et les
valeurs qu'il représente je crois
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre pardon que vous auriez intérêt
à écouter la voix qui devrait être
unanime ici de cette assemblée pour
retirer l'amendement
merci Monsieur bquet oui merci monsieur
le Président alors la troisème lame sur
ce sujet effectivement nous buvons vos
paroles chers collègue lescho vous savez
mon journal de chevet titré le 18
octobre la France crée un paradis fiscal
pour attirer la FIFA c'est les échos qui
disent ça une preuve d'amour en
direction de la FIFA alors on parle
beaucoup d'attractivité ça j'entends
beaucoup ce mot depuis hier avec
d'autres mots d'ailleurs je me demande
si certains n'ont pas en tête de changer
la devise de la République qui
deviendrait demain au lieu de liberté
égalité fraternité stabilité
attractivité et productivité c'est quand
même une idée incroyable les les les
collègues sont intervenu donc il s'agit
d'exonérer d'impôts sur les sociétés de
cotisation foncière sur les entreprises
et de CVAE les fédérations sportives
international qui brasse cela a été dit
des millions d'euros on le sait ce
régime fiscal concernerait précisément
34 fédérations sportives international
reconnu par le CO le monde croit savoir
que ce cadeau fiscal concernerait
particulièr les très lucratives
Fédération Internationale de
l'Automobile reconnue par le CIO depuis
2012 et dont le siège est à Paris la
Fédération internationale de football
américain et surtout la Fédération
internationale de football la FIFA qui a
une annexe à l'Hôtel de la Marine à la
Concorde rénové grâce au fond du Qatar
et non soumise à l'impôt sur les
sociétés qui compte pour l'URE une
vingtaine de salariés mais qui devrai en
transférer du siège de Zuric vers Paris
50 supplémentaires pour pour la période
2023-2026 la FIFA ESC comppte percevoir
11 milliards de dollars de revenus hors
Coupe du Monde monsieur Janny Infantino
son président aurait tapé du point sur
la table afin de bénéficier d'un régime
fiscal encore plus avantageux que dans
son canton de Zuric très connu chez les
spécialistes de la fiscalité donc
l'attractivité à la Suisse est déjà pas
si mal avec l'impôt sur les sociétés de
12 % bien supérieur à l'exonération
prévue par ce dispositif si bien qu'elle
a versé selon ses dire 2,7 millions de
dollars d'impôt et de taxes en 2022 non
franchement cette courche àess salotte
devient complètement
indécente le
1397 monsieur de la
S défendu le
94 Jean sanetas
allez-y merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre également
le groupe socialiste à travers
Jean-Jacques lazac et je rapporte cette
demande de suppression au nom au titre
au nom du groupe socialiste c'est
scandaleux c'est unique enfin tous les
mots ont étent utilisé de plus autour de
la FIFA c'est quand
même c'est quand même un peu sulfureux
il y a des mises en examen sur
l'attribution de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar enfin tout a été décrit vraiment
on ne comprend absolument pas par
rapport au monde du sport du monde du
sport amateur ce qui s'est passé pour
que vous euh
puissiez présenter un un un ce type
d'amendement et d'avantage fiscal pour
la FIFA alors oui la FIFA est dans notre
collimateur et dans notre
viseur madame Olivier pour le 2234
oui merci et bien comme les amendements
précédents nous nous proposons la
suppression de cet article il prévoit en
effet d'exonérer les fédérations
sportives internationales par reconnu
par le CIO de l'impôt sur les société de
la cotisation foncière des entreprises
de la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée
des entreprises et il exonère d'impôt
sur le revenu les salariés de ces
fédérations pour une durée de 5 ans euh
alors d'abord la dimension juridique de
ce nouveau régime fiscal n'est en rien
équilibré à l'objectif affichés
d'inciter les fédérations sportives
internationales de s'installer en France
se pose la question de l'égalité du
traitement à l'égard des charges public
voire de la conformité d'une telle
mesure avec la
Constitution et puis le respect du du
travail du Parlement en matière
fiscale la mise en place de ce régime
particulièrement avantageux est sans
commune mesure et porte atteinte au
principe du consentement à l'impôt
l'objectif de cet amendement plusieurs
l'ont dit avant moi c'est d'attirer la
FIFA et c'est d'autant plus
problématique quand même rappeler que la
FIFA n'a nullement besoin d'exonération
fiscale quand on sait que son chiffre
d'affaires entre 2019 et 2020 est de 7
milliards d'euros alors que la France
évoque régulièrement la concurrence
fiscale domageable de certains pays
européens par le biais de cet amendement
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
prend le même chemin et contredit sa
propre position enfin le gouvernement ne
cesse de nous signaler que des manœuvres
budgétaires sont de plus en plus
contraintes et que l'urgence est de
réduire le déficit merci
merci